what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so we are getting into Red Hood in
the outlaws are getting back into it
rather without hood
joining the Suicide Squad DC kind of
teasing the idea of him being there now
in reality if I'm being honest with you
guys I think this is DC kind of testing
the waters a little bit I really think
it is I think it's got low talent
company kind of experimenting a little
bit because when it comes to Jason Todd
he has for a long time been one of these
characters that DC wasn't really sure
what to do with and what this means is
this kind of a perfect storm it's a way
for DC to say he still come to the
vigilante type but he could pop up
anywhere and fight anybody at any point
in time and fans love that like they
love that element of his character which
makes him so cool and that's one of the
things that a run in that we'd run into
right in the last story arc we talked
about how Red Hood and Artemis and
bizarro had basically been operating out
of Gotham City and no one was really
supposed to know but at the same time
they were still following the extremists
charter of Red Hood in the outlaws which
was we want to exterminate crime in
Gotham City and so when you have the
various members of the bat family or at
least - Batman you know once they
realize what's going on the immediate
response is no and so they immediately
subdued Jason and Artemis and bizarro
and then handed them over to Amanda
Waller now in reality this was a pretty
heavy-handed tactic it was pretty
extreme especially with the bat family
knowing the consequences which is to say
that being thrown onto the Suicide Squad
basically means there's a very high
likelihood that you will die and even if
you don't there's really no coming back
and so this is a pretty big gamble by
the bat family to possibly even hand
over Jason Todd one of their owns who
Amanda Waller knowing what might happen
here but the other thing that ends up
going on is that when Jason is being
interrogated by like Captain Boomerang
and the other members of the squad one
of the questions they ask is if you're
not really part and parcel to the bat
family which is really not he's really
more of like a satellite member they're
like if you're not part and parcels with
a bat family then why the heck do you
have a bat symbol on your chest which at
that point activates and then just
electrocutes the hell out of everybody
and then that's that and it allows Jason
Todd to escape but I want to talk about
that for a second Jason is he's part of
the bat family but not entirely but he's
always just kind of been on the outside
he's always been kind of like a like a
satellite orbiting the solar system of
the bat family if that makes any sense
because he's his honor just sort of free
float out there and it's one of the best
aspects of his characters Jason Todd has
a kind of freedom in DC Comics that you
don't really see all that often but
again switching over to Holli
and switching over to Artemis the kind
of discussion between the two is
actually pretty amazing and to be honest
I'm really really excited to see like I
want to see the two of them like
crossover you know because Harley Quinn
starts asking like these crazy questions
or even in Amazon or are you just a
person pretending to be an Amazon you
know and then in turn you know Artemis
is like yes I'm definitely 100% Amazon
Halle was like all you do is drop names
you know it's funny because you know
Harley Quinn really is just crazy but
she's an entertaining crazy that's what
makes her so cool I mean in reality I
think that Amanda Connor and Jimmy Paul
Miatas Harley Quinn run is really really
interesting but I think that Harley
Quinn on the Suicide Squad is where she
really stands out because when it comes
to Scott Lowe Dell as a writer he is
nothing if not spectacular when it comes
to writing characters that he truly
understands he's amazing at that you
know and so ultimately this really kind
of results in Harley Quinn and an
artemis basically going coming to blows
is another and then like fighting but we
don't really see the fight between the
two of them least we to see Jason Todd
racing to them and then when he gets
there Artemis is basically defeated
Harley Quinn but then once the two of
them basically break free they end up
getting directly to where Amanda
Waller's at only to find now the bizarro
is having essentially a conversation
whether now this is the smartest move to
make when it comes to Red Hood when it
comes to Artemis they fight that's their
thing bizarro is smart and truly bizarro
could destroy Amanda Waller right I mean
you could just incinerator in her
entirety but you got it I mean one thing
you have to believe if you're going into
like the bait if you're going into the
Lions Den is there has to be all manner
of like safety protocols precautions
cameras all that different kinds of
stuff and so when it comes to something
like the Suicide Squad well it is Amanda
Waller's own personal pret project
because of all the missions the team has
gone on and because of all their
successes they've almost become kind of
Requirement kind of a necessity and so
if bazzara were for example to destroy
Amanda Waller it means most likely the
government would put somebody in her
place and then using evidence would try
convict and then sentence bizarro and
red hood and Artemis to serve their time
on the Suicide Squad so there'd really
be no benefit there not only that what
this does is it creates a bridge of
sorts that when it comes to Amanda
Waller she's one of these characters
were it's definitely better to be you
know on the devil's right hand then in
his path it's one of the best roles to
play and so it really is bizarro just
being smart here and so when he goes
through and and starts explaining
everything what we end up finding out is
that there's basically a place called a
colony and there's four of them spread
across a planet Earth but
of them is unstable thus getting ready
to basically collapse and they have to
sort essentially kind of restore the
core more or less and that if it
collapses it'll cause a massive ricochet
through the tectonic plates and
basically destroy the earth now on the
surface the response would be if this is
a planetary threat then why doesn't
anybody know about it but notice this it
fits in perfect with the Suicide Squad
because that team is nothing if not a
wet work team
that that's all they are no one's really
supposed to know that they're there
they're supposed to be in and out
without drawing any attention or any
eyes a lot of it's because the missions
are going on are usually illegal and so
when when that's when that's the case
with all the secrets Amanda Waller keeps
you would have to believe that something
like this she would keep under wraps
that nobody would really know about it
now of course this is also Scott Liddell
kind of wrapping up his own plot threats
and what I mean here is back when a new
52 first launched back in 2012 June 11
2012 what you had is you had Skyler Dell
riding the Teen Titans with the
intention of kind of creating their own
anti team that is to say a team that was
a direct antithesis to the Teen Titans
themselves and this really came in the
form of the Ravagers now with the
Ravagers came a guy called called
harvest and the way the story was told
he was basically a villain from like the
31st century that hated metahumans and
so the idea was to travel back to the
modern day find a way to destroy
metahumans by creating his own Ravagers
which was to essentially grab metahumans
and normal humans experiment on their
genes amplify their powers modify their
powers take them away whatever give them
to people who were normal humans and
then send them out for the purpose of
like wiping out metahumans that's led
them into direct conflict with the Teen
Titans and ultimately harvest was
defeated and so it was a pretty cool
situation to see unfold and so what this
does is it means that like Scott Liddell
is wrapping up his own cloth ribs it's a
way to kind of nip ease these tail
little tidbits of new 52 story arcs and
sort of let them be washed away and so
with the Suicide Squad and the outlaws
teaming up and traveling to the colony
what this does is it leads to some
pretty interesting conversations most
notably between Red Hood and between
between Killer Croc once the groups are
basically split up you know when you end
up having uh you know bizarro going with
with Captain Boomerang and with Deadshot
Killer Croc teaming up with Red Hood and
then of course Harley Quinn and Artemis
going off
Killer Croc starts talking to Jason and
what he says is where you're at right
now in this moment like this this road
do your walking being the guy who's
going to quote-unquote kill criminals
it's a very dangerous path that you're
on
if you take one misstep you make one bad
choice you're going to end up becoming a
pill you're gonna end up right here on
the Suicide Squad
a path that you're on that's only ever
going to lead you to pretty bad places
now this is where things start to get a
little bit murky and the reason why is
because at the end of Teen Titans annual
number three in 2014 wherever it was
that it came out what you ended up
having was the colony where harvest was
at essentially exploding with him
trapped inside wild like cassie
sandsmark and and Tim Drake and all
those guys looked on like Raven and all
them while they looked on and watch the
whole thing unfold and so all indication
whether the character died and so as far
as I'm aware we don't know how we got
from the end of that story to this part
right here where he's basically pinned
up and crucified maybe though bees like
some middle ground fill-ins story I'm
not a hundred percent sure but again it
seems to be Scott Liddell sort of
revisiting and taking a look back at his
own story so it is kind of cool because
I think the concept of harvest was an
interesting idea I don't think there was
really enough time to flesh it out
because I don't think the Teen Titans
were as well received as DC was hoping I
think a lot of people were sort of
expecting a return to the team they saw
from TV as opposed to a whole new line
of Teen Titans that and stuff like Bart
Allen or is it Bart or or whatever it is
things like that kind of did not do well
but still getting into the actual core
of the colony and basically stabilizing
everything it's pretty straightforward I
mean it's again this is a two issue
story it's not super complex there's not
a whole lot of in-depth plot threads
here again one of the big talking points
that goes on is Killer Croc and Red Hood
now again this is an awesome
conversation because Killer Croc talking
to Red Hood he basically says look man
this idea you have of just annihilating
criminals everywhere you find them is
not necessarily the breaths a best
approach to take and whether whether the
question being asked is why we actually
get some pretty good wisdom from Killer
Croc here and it's really hints at how
Killer Croc views Batman like Killer
Croc response is well you yourself are a
walking talking man of Redemption like
when you came back and you faced off
against Batman as the Red Hood when you
first showed up but you are a guy who
was looking to just annihilate all the
criminals you seemed to be beyond
redemption but then you started spending
time with Arsenal and Arsenal made you a
better person in turn you are where you
are right now
if there's hope for you there has to be
hope for other people and I don't
believe this is an opinion that Killer
Croc came to of his own volition I think
it's something that Batman inspired by
virtue of his actions and it's kind of
cool because if that's true what it
would mean is that Batman as a character
even if on a miniscule level does have
impact on the criminals of Gotham
there's got to be some measure of
respect there you know even if it's only
for the fact that Batman doesn't just
kill Killer Croc right off the bat it's
a bit of respect there that's kind of
being sent to Jason because what's
happening here is is very true you know
Jason is one false step away he's one
miscalculation he's one wrongful-death
away from being shanghaied and pressed
oppress gained onto the Suicide Squad to
being a tried and true criminal in the
underworld and that's why he'll across
says you can't stay this course forever
if you keep doing this eventually it'll
become who you are it won't just be a
belief that you have
it'll be who you are as a human being
but you have friends you've got
corriander you've got bizarro you've got
people who are a part of you that can
help bring you back that's so it's cool
because what this means is it
potentially sets the stage for like Red
Hood to leave the outlaws it potentially
sets the stage for him to like disband
the team you'll end up seeing this sort
of reformation with these various
characters that's what this is setting
the stage for and that's why this is so
cool
and so where you end up having like
Deadshot and you end up having Captain
Boomerang who basically you know take
out the core more-or-less kind of
stabilize the the colony keep it from
like disrupting or from exploding in its
entirety
this basically sets things back to
rights and it kind of happens off panel
you don't really see a whole lot of it
it's just kind of a theme that takes
place because it's not really a main
part of the story but it is a cool bit
of a discussion here because what this
means is it sets the bigger stage here
it sets a much bigger set of events
where the outlaws are basically allowed
to go and Amanda Waller does run or
Mille little bit of time to hear saying
what one day you're gonna screw up and
then I'm gonna have you on my team you
know and so on and so forth you know
I'll get you pretty and your little dog
too
well you basically get that kind of
thing going on what happens when we
transition back to the headquarters of
Red Hood and Artemis they have this kind
of a discussion about bizarro as bizarro
looks on and what they say is this whole
situation unfolded largely because of
him which is to say their actions
alongside the Suicide Squad and so on
and so forth then being all you know
being being brought to the Suicide Squad
was a result of all their actions but
how the events unfolded was because of
bizarro and what this means is that
bizarro in some fashion is kind of
graduating out from under the guidance
of Jason Todd and and Artemis and
liberal eventually want to leave and go
out and do his own thing he's rapidly
leaving them behind
in intelligence and and so on and so
forth and when that time comes can
bizarro be trusted can they trust him to
go out and to do his own thing can they
trust him to
out and and be a hero out there in the
world because what happens if he does
what happens if bizarro leaves the
purview that the guidance of Artemis and
Red Hood and then he begins to
degenerate will he be a dangerous a
planetary threat how will that unfold
will it be the fault of Jason and
Artemis so again it really sets the
stage for kind of the disbanding of the
team whether as a natural progression or
because people just kind of grow out of
it but with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this video to an end if you
are new here two comments explained make
sure you guys at the sub button to
become part of the robb core if you guys
enjoy this video make sure you drop a
like and yeah I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]
[Music]